trees need plenty of water even after
they've been chopped down logs from all
over the world to stacked here Axl gross
says the really large ones are the best
for making veneers but the tree must
have other qualities as well
we read the bark you can see scars here
where small branches were this is no
good for veneer the next candidate is a
log of warm up from Slovakia the timber
is cut into sections but growth has seen
better would not this tree either it's
big this not really you come why not
drum it's too old they didn't know you
couldn't see it from the outside it
looked good standing in the forest but
here's this flaw a hole that likely runs
through the base the log will be milled
anyway the wood may be suitable for
furniture workers at the veneer factory
classify the lumber for use dealers say
oak a typical German wood is really
popular again at the moment especially
in Asia the sheets of veneer are cut
into a paper-thin 0.6 millimeters then
they have to be bone dry
the final cut is the last chance to
discover floors the company headquarters
is in karlsruhe a well-traveled CEO Axl
grow inherited the business from his
father all the lumber that's purchased
around the world ends up here after
milling an employee shows the boss a
pleasant surprise this mahogany log from
the ivory coast is a rarity in the
spring of 2013 the import of illegally
fell timber to Germany was banned to put
a stop to trade in rare woods now every
log must come with documentation that it
was legally harvested and imported the
importer must guarantee that otherwise
we can't buy wood from him and did he
guarantee it yeah pressure to refuse to
do business with some countries as
growing is good i [ __ ] vinegar in some
places the political situation makes it
impossible the corruption is obvious we
don't buy wood in places like that and
haven't in ages this is a positive
example for the industry it's a tree
that can be used and will earn plenty
for the communities or forest owners and
will even make money with it too the log
is expected to bring around 35 thousand
euros its wood will be offered to
customers who want luxury products this
carpenter from cars row is looking for
veneers for closets in a private home he
says his customers ask him more and more
about the source of the wood if they're
going to spend a lot of money they
prefer veneer over synthetics
nevertheless the market for veneers has
contracted by half many of shawn andrews
competitors have closed up shop this
bill is not the cheap stuff is killing
us you simply cannot sell a unique
natural forest product that took a
century to grow at a loss it can't be
done it isn't sustainable we've got to
fight this trend that's the right thing
to do and it means that wood is going to
become expensive luxurious and valuable
and it won't be sold at run-of-the-mill
furniture stores its cost won't allow
for that Axl gross is a future for his
veneers in luxury car interiors he heads
into the Black Forest which is located
near the company's headquarters grow
says one of germany's best-known forests
is still healthy and isn't a monoculture
the lumber here is too good to use for
cheap furniture or paper gross says he
likes looking for trees vest the 55 year
old was always in the woods with his
father and studied forestry later on he
once wanted to go to Brazil to save the
rainforests now he's in the lumber
business I asks if it makes him sad to
see trees made into doors no absolutely
not using wood is very rational this
forest wouldn't be as beautiful if a
tree weren't harvested now and then it
gives the other space to grow not foxy
grow adds that when trees have a real
value and a good price it also helps to
conserve the forests where they grow